hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today Jeff Goldblum is
weird on Conan a compilation I'm excited
to check this out as a top reward to
your video request from a new patron
named Sam Smith I'm wearing this shirt
just for you I'll explain why later on
in the video P you already know why Sam
I'm so happy who doesn't love Jeff
Goldblum Conan O'Brien needs a friend
his podcast it's free to listen to you
guys if you have Apple podcast I would
also say that one of the best episodes
is the one with Jeff gold it's
hysterical pure gold bloomin ism's
this is compiled from a channel called
nautical G oh your nautical gee that is
my new nickname when you're at sea
that's weird and changing this channel
too you can take the real rejects
nautical hey you let's watch this
I used to try the terrifying interview
surprise that's not a surprise
you know yes you were even oh you're
very head area
you looked you look handsome and like
you would have a six-pack or an 18
Packer weight you can tell by looking at
my head area that I have a six-pack yeah
we just found out he's an alien in your
head area people are talking thank
someone from another planet my crazy
okay I think weirdest interview
[Music]
I like you a lot you've been coming on
as a guest from that years we've
establishes an attraction and so I'm
sorry you almost died much some candy
out here drink that was that was
inappropriate I'm sorry I apologize now
it was a halls it was a halls and I
thought that being a little um
ventilated would give me some crystal
warmth and a nice up a nice uh you know
you want everything
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
silky smooth
[Applause]
[Music]
are you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
while you were saying
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't think any of this is arable
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
he's a very sensual stroking the
furniture you're writing in here I don't
have I do can you see what that says
glasses won't help you oh my god you're
blind this is crazy
you need looks like a cloud of beef
bouillon right now asymmetrical it's
that's right right on the nose
that's an asymmetric I used I used to
try the terrifying interview
my girlfriend actually Emily Livingston
how you tell a secret you know into a TV
camera Emily and she stood in the store
in front of me and her sweet breath on
my face and and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ask me how I enjoyed the party last
night you gave the child his toy and
well I you know you look good good to me
now you know how your clear glasses wise
yeah
I apologize everyone this probably won't
air yeah gone too soon
I'm gonna watch 45-minute ass if I was
never gonna end
in a good way in a good way what makes
their juxtaposition so engaging is Jeff
Goldblum is very expressive and
eccentric and very animated sensual in
his presence yeah very comfortable
within his own skin not afraid to be
comfortable around anyone
whereas Conan while he's like so great
with yes and and being able to go along
with any bit or whatever ether Ives a
lot off of insecurity and
self-deprecating humor uncomfortability
and so they're so opposite with one
another what makes I think their
dynamics and interview episodes so great
Conan is one of the people who like he's
great at making bits out of finding what
Jeff Goldblum does to be weird you're
like we all know Geoff Colvin was we
were always like hah we love that we
love how weird isn't he reacts in a way
he actually could throws him off but I
don't think it actually throws Conan off
but he acts like it's you know makes him
unsettled and I think that's what makes
what watching them or listening and that
even in the podcast it's so delightful
and in the podcast I really think I
should listen to it if there's one
episode check out should be that one in
the Timothy Olyphant one let the Geoff
Goldman one especially because you do
see a different engagement that Conan
has with Geoff Gollum an hour-long
interview format as opposed to this
where he no it's very physical bit
performance at the TV well yeah it's
interesting to watch too because they
make a good comedic duo in a way because
Jeff Goldblum is just so fun flappable
like yeah even when Conan is being a
foil to him or pointing out that what
he's doing is funky like you seems like
he gets a kick out of making Conan feel
that way yeah so and it's cool because
you get to see really the dynamic of the
interview because even though they are
really off-the-cuff and they're not
using the pre questions probably as much
you do yeah watch Conan sort of check in
do the work sort of because you know
he'll pick things - yeah file off of
to challenge yeah you know Jeff on and
yeah it creates that really fun vibe
where like Conan is almost he's our guy
he's like our cipher to like walk us
through this weird Jeff Goldblum
experience together and yeah it just
makes those bits really endearing
because then you know Jeff Goldblum is
doing his whimsical he reminds me of
like you know that Simpsons episode
where mr. burns he's like coming out of
the woods and he's all green and his
eyes are super diable yeah I think
there's an alien and he's really mr.
burns yeah yeah Jeff Goldblum is just
like that if you just learned to live
you know like if you didn't ever come
out of that state if you lived left
there so opposite they clearly like each
other yeah yeah they clearly respond to
each other this is like SATA beats a
perfect example of like opposites that
attract and not and maybe as sexual if
they've done but it is a comedic
palpable way and I love it because there
are two different types of performers
and entertainers and just completely
different individuals so you watch them
collide it makes this for a great
television because you know coding like
thrives off of it all those jokes about
it this is an arable or whatever like
this that's like the kind of [ __ ] he
loves oh yeah I mean it reminded me of a
different version of a shlonsky routine
or something like that where you have
conan reacting to a character who has
their specific character trait is he
he's really dry and with the golem he's
really kooky and eccentric and yet you
get so yeah it's that it's a similar
dynamic to me but on you know the
interview side of things I've always
wanted to do this and I hope somebody
does I feel like you could take that
episode of conan needs a friend and you
could make just a supercut of all the
times Jeff makes a sound just goes mmm
you can make like a 10-minute super cut
of only those noises let's pile of
Cohen's impression of him
because that is like the closest I'll
ever get to a Jeff Goldblum yes and the
glasses - I like the glasses became like
a constant bit even over what you could
tell we're different interviews with
different pairs of well nautical gee
thanks for putting this together
Sam Smith thanks for requesting this my
do you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification really
get notified whenever got a video
Sam is new to the patreon page he's from
Brisbane Australia who Australia
Australia Dickman G oh yeah yeah nicole
kidman that's terrible
it's Nicole Kidman there you go Hickman
sim sim you Smith James Warren now
you're doing it terrible it's Jame one
requested this Sam Smith and he's from
Brisbane Australia and he said he
started watching us way back when for
the amazing spider-man 2 trailer
reactions hence I wear this shirt in
your honor today Sam thank you so much
and dude giving you a classic shout out
here man look out your name biblical
means God has heard Smith who means to
smite or strike which you have done who
you've been heard by me I am God and you
have struck in our patreon page with a
phat pledge for the month of October
making it rain so dude you have lived up
to your name now we will use this pledge
money to well spending remember the hell
we want see you Sam peace no well barely
so thank you bye